read bell hooks then get back to me it's
not my job to educate you I'm a black
woman than you'll love bell hooks ah you
participated in a trolling cliche Milton
the homework Giver this is what a troll
can't be bothered to explain why they
disagree with a given post so they
outsource the argument read this article
then get back to me you should go to
your local library and check out a copy
of such-and-such book by filling a blank
author if you haven't seen the brilliant
documentary blah blah blah you're really
not equipped to have an opinion on this
issue
hey thanks teach who knew you were so
good at reading and watching stuff it
tells you how to feel you nerd here
we've been all wasting our time forming
our own opinions like a bunch of novices
listen school sucked the first time
around and homework was probably the
number one reason nobody's looking for
extra credit assignments off Facebook so
unless you have a link to the Cliff's
Notes version of the article that you
skim please proceed directly to
detention ass dismissed
ha ha ha as it as my class
[Music]